hey car Nakamura claimed Redemption
after a dramatic win over Magnus Carlson
in the losers bracket and twice earned
Vengeance against Fabiano caruana Hikaru
is the champion of the chessable Masters
both players traded wins in the first
two games and in the third Hikaru
capitalized on a fatal Mistake by
Fabiano in a hard-fought battle in the
fourth game Hikaru outlasted Fabi to
gain another Victory under time pressure
and to force a grand finals reset as
this was Bobby's first match loss Hikaru
would need to win a second match Hikaru
expertly countered Bobby's attacks in
the opening game of the reset in
dangerous time pressure Hikaru punished
Fabi yet again and obtained a victory
that appeared to seal the deal but in
the next game instead of playing it safe
Hikaru went for a risky tactic that
backfired dramatically Bobby did not let
this opportunity slip and force the
match to Armageddon in Armageddon Hikaru
won the bid for the black pieces Fabiano
started to get excited with a potential
win on the board but then the roles
reversed and